ja und das sind unfassbare Szenen beim
Kongress der Kommunistischen Partei in
China na der ehemalige Staatspräsident
der Volksrepublik hooding Tao wird aus
dem Saal geführt huh scheint überrascht
steht nur widerwillig auf weiß offenbar
selbst nicht was da gerade passiert
erscheint noch sein Nachfolger cheating
Fragen zu wollen der mit versteinerter
Mine neben ihm sitzt dann wird er aus
dem Saal eskortiert eine klare
Machtdemonstration des Präsidenten Chi
die staatliche Nachrichtenagentur Chi
und Hua die behauptete später das Schuh
den Saal verlassen habe weil es ihn
nicht gut gegangen sei doch die
Videoaufnahmen zeigen schon sehr
deutlich der exchart-chef weigerte sich
zuerst aufzustehen puddingtau stand für
einen Führungsstil den Ping jetzt
abgeschafft hat während seiner Zeit als
Parteichef stimmte sich HU mit den
Fraktionen innerhalb der Partei ab
Widerspruch war damals noch möglich und
diese Machtdemonstration von Chi jetzt
also eine neue Zäsur für China und
seinen Machteinfluss will sie jetzt auch
in Deutschland investieren ist rot eine
gefährliche Abhängigkeit denn es geht um
kritische Infrastruktur sechs
Ministerien raten zwar von einer
chinesischen Beteiligung am Hamburger
Hafen ab aber SPD-Chef lasking bei weint
es dürfte gegenüber China nicht zu
ähnlichen Abhängigkeiten kommen wie bei
Russland nur Kanzler Olaf Scholz der
will den Deal jetzt tatsächlich
durchziehen
der Hamburger Hafen das Tor zur Welt
würde jetzt zum Chinesen die chinesische
staatsreederei Costco will Anteile des
Hamburger Hafenbetreibers haha la
übernehmen mit Wohlwollen von Kanzler
Scholz doch nicht nur
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck ist
dagegen will den Deal stoppen
Deutschland werde sich so weiter
abhängig machen von den Machthabern in
Peking Tatsache ist da China schon heute
wichtigster Kunde des Hafens sei könnte
durch die geplante Beteiligung am
Container Terminal einer
pressungspotenzial entstehen insgesamt
ist es richtig dass wir gelernt haben
dass
Abhängigkeiten von Ländern die dann
möglicherweise ihre eigenen Interessen
in diese Abhängigkeiten hineinspielen
also uns dann
erpressen wollen nicht mehr nur ein
abstraktes Phänomen sind sondern Gas
Russland Realität in dieser Welt sind
und wir sollten diese Fehler nicht
wiederholen mit mehr als einem Drittel
wollen die Chinesen sich am Container
Terminal tollerot beteiligen doch wie
gefährlich ist das greift China damit
nach einer unserer wichtigsten
Infrastrukturen schließlich hätte die
Kommunistische Partei unter dem
Allmächtigen Bing dann noch mehr
Einfluss in Deutschland
insgesamt sechs deutsche
Bundesministerien haben das
hafengeschäft abgelehnt doch
Bundeskanzler Scholz lässt das offenbar
kalt er will den Deal durchsetzen weil
es sich beim Hamburger Hafen um
kritische Infrastruktur handelt hatte
das federführende Wirtschaftsministerium
ein
investitionsprüfungsverfahren gestartet
das Thema wurde also bereits zur
endgültigen Ablehnung in Bundeskabinett
angemeldet das Kanzleramt hat das
Prüfverfahren nicht auf die Tagesordnung
genommen heißt es ein Kabinettsbeschluss
der für ein verboten notwendig ist kann
damit nicht gefasst werden stattdessen
soll das Kanzleramt die Suche nach einem
Kompromiss angeordnet haben damit das
Geschäft doch noch genehmigt werden kann
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit Bild
Chefredakteur Johannes Boje schönen
guten Morgen Johannes guten morgen ist
schon ein bisschen unfassbar sechs
Ministerien sind dagegen quasi alle
warnen alle sagen Olaf Scholz bitte nein
tun sie das nicht und der Kanzler sagt
es mir egal ich will es einfach
durchziehen was reitet Ihnen warum macht
er das wahrscheinlich wird der Kanzler
in zehn Jahren im Nachhinein sagen ich
habe es immer gewusst dass eine
schlechte Idee war denn genau das hatte
Kanzler jetzt hier gemacht beim Thema
Russland wo wir in unsere Energie
Sicherheit und Versorgung sind wir ja
abhängig von Russland und jetzt sagt der
Kanzler er habe es ja immer gewusst so
als hätte er damit nichts zu tun gehabt
der war natürlich beteiligt uns an
Russland auszuliefern was die
Energiepolitik betrifft und jetzt macht
er genau das gleiche noch mal mit China
Hamburg wo er ja auch lange
Politiker war und Bürgermeister war hat
schon immer ein enges Verhältnis zu
China das kommt durch den Hafen das
kommt durch den internationalen Handel
und man merkt eben dass Olaf Scholz
China nicht vor den Kopf stoßen möchte
er reist Anfang November auch nach
Peking er will dort nicht mit leeren
Händen aufschlagen und deswegen möchte
er dieses Stück deutscher Infrastruktur
dieses Terminal im Hamburger Hafen
teilweise an China verkaufen ist also
deiner Meinung nach auch ein Stück weit
Angst geschrieben
Angst getrieben vielleicht nicht
unbedingt sondern er ist nicht durch
Sorge getrieben und das müsste er sein
er müsste es wirklich klar erkennen und
sehen hier öffnet man China immer weiter
die Tür denn was wir ja sehen ist eine
Strategie die China seit vielen vielen
Jahren verfolgt nämlich als freundlicher
Handelspartner durch die Tür dann die
Machtposition ausbauen und uns dann
systematisch Schwächen und alle die
jetzt noch dem Gedanken verhaftet sind
Mensch man kann doch mit China Handel
machen was ist denn dabei es ist ja nur
Handel es ist ein freier Markt die
können doch was kaufen auch wie das
Münchner Unternehmen Sixt das einfach
mal 100.000 Fahrzeuge von einem
chinesischen Konzern kauft ja
alle die so noch denken verkennen dass
China damit eine Machtposition bei uns
aufbaut und das China diese
Machtposition in anderen Ländern
Stichwort Sri Lanka Stichwort
afrikanische Staaten schon
ausnutzt und das wird uns auch drohen
wir werden vollkommen abhängig werden
tatsächlich ist China aber nun auch ein
wichtiger Handelspartner von Deutschland
die Beziehung jetzt komplett zu kappen
wäre ja auch keine Option das heißt für
Olaf Scholz irgendwie ja eine etwas
merkwürdige patzsituation wie könnte
denn tatsächlich eine vernünftige
China-Politik Aussehen in der man sagt
ja man treibt vernünftigen Handel aber
man macht sich eben nicht komplett
abhängig du hast das die Aussage deiner
eigene Aussage Beziehungen komplett
Kappen sofort so locker abgetan mit wäre
ja auch keine Option es ist eine doch
ich ich ich teile es für jetzt für die
absolute Gegenwart auch aber wir werden
uns schon wesentlich radikaler fragen
müssen wie wir mit China umgehen wollen
denn china investiert massiv in Militär
rüstet massiv auf bedroht taiwan hat
sich Hongkong gegriffen es handelt sich
tatsächlich um einen militärischen
Aggressor und wenn wir weiterhin nur
unter der Überschrift Handelspartner
nachdenken werden wir immer weiter ins
Hintertreffen kommen weil in China
redet zumindest hinter geschlossenen
Türen kein Mensch mehr über den Westen
nur noch als Handelspartner in China ist
den völlig klar das ist ein Teil der
Welt den wollen wir zumindest ökonomisch
vollkommen erobern und kontrollieren und
das müssen wir anerkennen und dann
müssen wir entscheiden wie gehen wir
damit um und dann stellen sich solche
Fragen wie beim Hamburger Hafen gar
nicht mehr sondern dann stellen sich
ganz andere Fragen und es wäre Europa
sehr gut angeraten sich
auf allen viel radikaleren Standpunkt zu
stellen und zu gucken dass man die
wirtschaftliche dominanzinas
zurückdrängt und eigene Stärke wieder
aufbaut
dass wir jetzt Szenen gesehen haben in
Peking wie ja die Macht demonstriert
wurde von shivia sein Vorgänger da
einfach aus dem Saal hat führen lassen
was glaubst du was bedeutet das jetzt
auch für China ist das tatsächlich eine
neue Zäsur eine neue Ära die da jetzt
noch mal anbricht mit dieser Macht
Manifestation vielleicht keine neue Ära
aber es manifestiert sich etwas ja
der jetzige regierungs- und Staatschef
Staatschef ist ohnehin jemand der schon
seine drei Amtsperioden eigentlich
hinter sich hat ja jetzt legt er noch
eine drauf das war so nicht vorgesehen
sein Vorgänger war da dagegen dass
abführend vor der versammelten
Weltpresse eine einzige
Machtdemonstration erinnert übrigens
auch sehr an
sozialistische Diktaturen was China ja
ist
früher hat man dann immer noch aus dem
nächsten Raum die Gewehrschüsse gehört
wo die Leute dann erschossen wurden
soweit ist man hier nicht gegangen aber
man fragt sich schon wo ist der jetzt
eigentlich der abgeführt wurde und dann
natürlich direkt am Tag danach die große
Propaganda Lüge dem ging es nicht gut ja
und da auch das übrigens eine
Machtdemonstration wir können Euch
zeigen wie es ist und wir können euch
danach komplett belügen das ist wirklich
wie in einer
Dystopie wie in einer schrecklichen
Nordkorea oder wenn man an die Literatur
denkt 1984 das berühmte Buch über
die sozialistische Dystopie 2 + 2 ist 5
ich kann es dem Volk erzählen irgendwann
wird es mir schon glauben so ist China
mittlerweile drauf Johannes abschließ
die Frage noch ganz kurz wie gefährlich
ist dieser Mann für China und auch den
Rest der Welt
ja für China nur insofern gefährlich als
er die Menschen im Land einsperrt
interniert in Lager schickt die durchaus
an Konzentrationslager denken lassen
insbesondere die oliguren also sehr
gefährlich aber gleichzeitig baut er
natürlich auch die Machtposition Chinas
weiter aus für die Welt ist er
brandgefährlich
ihm ist zuzutrauen was Putin aller
Voraussicht glücklicherweise nicht
schaffen wird nämlich den Dritten
Weltkrieg zu entfesseln sagt Johannes
Boje bildchef Dankeschön dass du bei uns
warst danke euch
[Musik]